very good morning to you were you a bit
disappointed that there wasn't a big
breakthrough moment for Jeremy Corbyn
last night I think last night we saw a
state's person dignified and consistent
and I think those values shone through
and I think it was a really good
performance by by Jeremy Corbyn so I
think as we approach the appalling day
people have that in their minds that
there is somebody who could we could be
proud of on the world stage and by
comparison not be embarrassed about if
Boris Johnson will just stand on front
on Thursday you do have a proper
breakthrough and to close those polls
you do need a bit of a of a
game-changing moment today you're
talking about it changing every bus into
an electric bus is that going to
convince anybody well I think people do
know how important their bus services
are there's so many people now isolated
we've lost 3,000 bus services across
England since 2010 we're talking about
putting those back we're talking about
making those buses free for people under
the age of 25 and of course the climate
change crisis all the rides all our
everything that we do so we've got to
address that by converting our buses
amongst other things from internal
combustion engines to deep to electric
and that's what this program is about
and this will drastically reduce
emissions and improve air quality and of
course the consequent health benefits
ar-ar-ar-ar obvious but this makes our
our communities better connected people
getting to to school to hospitals to
work this is a hugely important matter
and buses are the most important port
mode of public transport and we want to
integrate that with other modes as well
but it's important to get that shift
from most vehicles to public transport
and this is a major contribution to it
and I've seen that our
environmental approach has been
well-regarded by commentators have
looked at all the party's manifesto so
it said it's something I'm very proud of
and I think you've got to take it in the
wider picture and the wider picture is
how do you pay for it four billion
pounds here four billion pounds where's
that coming from
well that's from our green
transformation fund we are borrowing
that money to invest in this and of
course people do recognise that the
climate crisis is an existential crisis
for our planet so we have to take major
steps major interventions to bring this
about so it's in and of course that will
hugely benefit our economy in terms of
our industrial strategy in terms of the
buses that we're going to build to
fulfill this objective so there's
there's winds here right across from
jobs from public health to the
environment and of course connectivity
and economic growth and prosperity so it
hits all of those those marks and I
think people will receive it very well
so in terms of game changes I don't
think people are ignoring the climate
crisis and will welcome this sort of
initiative from the Labour Party but
people are beginning to look have done
maybe food since it was launched at the
Labor manifesto and saying you know are
you just spending the same money several
times four billion pounds for this
scheme hangover over a 10-year period
you've got 58 billion for the the waspy
women's pension fund you've got a rail
fair price cut of 1.5 billion pounds a
year you've got all the nationalization
schemes which are going to cost huge
amounts of money and you know you keep
saying you're a lot of this not all of
it but a lot of it is going to be funded
by borrowing where on earth does that
leave the country you can understand why
people are looking at that with a degree
of skepticism
well I I think it's accepted in terms of
economists practice to borrow to invest
in your economy to grow your economy and
to get those returns from it but of
course you're quite right we've
identified the existing funds and we've
looked the vehicle excise duty fund and
and rather than have it dedicated the
word that the Tories would would would
describe we are saying that that should
be a sustainable transport fund and
utilize those funds to get that modal
shift into cycling into walking into
buses to get young people able to use
our public transport systems and of
course repair our local roads at the
same time so we're repurposing that fund
there already exists in a more
intelligent and responsive way to the
crisis that we face and whereas many
economies would it would agree with you
that you you can borrow to invest and to
boost an economy they're also economists
you turn around and say well look you
mean you're penalizing businesses
there's concern about some of the
commitments to small business that the
Federation for small business we're
raising concerns about yesterday you're
you're looking at an increasingly narrow
tax base for funding a lot of this they
say it's just too delicate to precarious
a situation to base their nation's
finances up well unders an awful lot of
economists who've signed a letter in the
Financial Times and they recognize the
veracity of what we're saying and
they're there they're supportive of our
plan and of course we are saying that 95
percent of the of the working population
will pay no more tax no more national
insurance contributions and we're
looking to the very richest in our
society and those corporate entities who
had the advantage of major tax cuts to
pay a little bit more and of course
businesses do benefit from an educated
workforce and a healthy workforce and
they want to see investment in the info
so that they can continue to trade and
do well but in terms of small businesses
we are making sure that the rates of tax
that they pay are asked are a markedly
lower than the larger corporations but
importantly Becky long barely is
announced a business directly
development agency that will assist
small businesses to navigate their way
through some of the complex procurement
processes to enable them to prosper and
secure contracts in that way so there's
a whole range of things that will
benefit our entire economy our entire
communities and I would I'm recommending
this to people because I think it does
address the needs of the country as we
face them today you said no more tax for
those on lower and middle-income that's
not true is it I mean you may be making
a commitment to no more income tax but
that doesn't mean no more tax well well
it does we're not going to be raising
the rate of tax for a ninety five
percent of the population so we're
looking to the the top five percent to
make their contribution and and they're
able to do that and I'm sure many will
want to do that because they are not
going to be prepared to continue to live
in a country where we've got so many
people homeless with children in poverty
and we have a proliferation of food
banks and soup kitchens in the United
Kingdom in 2019 I think people are
prepared to do that and and we are
looking to people on lower incomes and
we're introducing a whole raft of
measures that will financially be to
their betterment in terms of not just
raising their incomes in public services
increasing the minimum wage to 10 pounds
an hour but all the other measures that
we're introducing in terms of addressing
heating costs by insulating homes and so
on and so forth John McDonald has set
that out and people will be better off
under a Labour government and that is
beyond beyond any debate whatsoever
because it's been clearly set out this
will have a direct bearing on people's
day-to-day lives I don't think
anything's beyond debate let's be honest
look can we talk about that the NHS
because see
this election campaign started in Jeremy
Corbyn and others who said the NHS was
gonna be up for sale was up for sale to
America denied by the Prime Minister
denied by the President of the United
States then mr. Corbin starts waving
about a document which he said proved
that the NHS was up for post brexit
discussion there is now a serious
question as to whether that document
came from Russia whether indeed it is
genuine at all do you regret that you've
ended up at the center of that
particular row well let's just get it
right Steve the document came from Her
Majesty's Government and the reason is
anybody who I mean there were questions
there were questions raised only this
week about whether it actually was a
genuine document because of some of the
language used in it I think when you had
Liam Fox I was on your program awesome
or another one he didn't doubt the
accuracy of that document he didn't
argue with its content and I just asked
the question what are we concerned about
the veracity of the document or where it
came from and and and if a government
spokesman a person wants to come up and
say it's not our document it is
inaccurate we have not had these
meetings Liam Fox was not in America
having those conversations with American
officials and American farmer then so be
it but as I understand it it isn't in
doubt that it's a genuine document and
of course you've just had a senior civil
servant a British senior civil servant
in the United States resigning because
she's not prepared to put up with the
half truths that are professed by this
government we are clear you say you
don't care if this document effectively
came from the Kremlin I do I do Steve
and that is why I've repeatedly asked
for the government to publish their
Intelligence and Security Committee a
report what it what have they got to
hide they really can't have it both ways
I want to know what's in that report I
do want to know the extent to which any
other state would be interfering in our
affairs electoral or otherwise but I
also want to know what my government is
doing on my behalf and on your behalf
and they're having conversations about
the future our NHS we want to know
because if that's going to lead to vast
increases in in costs for our medication
and our prescriptions then that's going
to be critically important if that
undermines our NHS we'll all live to
regret it so we have to have a guarantee
but it's isn't giving it sorry it's it's
a bit of a difficult circle to square
isn't it when you're saying that you
have consumer you are concerned if this
document came from Russia it is looking
like
according to companies like Reddit that
it was linked to Russia in some way
therefore some sort of interference in
our electoral process if you're
uncomfortable with that how can you be
comfortable with Jeremy Corbyn waving it
about at a news conference well Steven
it's the document true
is it accurate is what is it in it
accepted as being a genuine recital of
the British government's position I mean
surely that what's more important the
veracity of the document or how it came
to be in our hands you've got you know
this should worry us I'm very concerned
that there could be interference and
that's why I'm saying in clear terms
published the report from Intelligence
and Security Committee and let's all be
knowing but my goodness I don't want to
be kept in the dark about the
government's plans for our NHS or
alternatively about the trading
relationships between within our own
country between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland we should have that out
in the open so we can all see what is
being done on our behalf and that's the
issue at stake here so I don't unless
somebody's going to tell me that these
are fictitious and fake documents I
think we're in the realms of trying to
get to the bottom of what our government
is up to on our behalf and
Donald good to talk to you this morning
thank you thank you